cheminées de l'intérieur la parole est à
monsieur alain chrétien merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre
insupportable les images de dirigeants
d'air france
molestés lyncher par soi disant
syndicalistes sont insupportables elle
tourne en boucle sur toutes les
télévisions du monde
elles sont désastreuses pour l'image de
la compagnie engagés dans une
concurrence féroce
voilà plusieurs semaines qu'un bras de
fer sans issue s'est engagée entre
certains personnels intransigeant et une
direction acculé à prendre des mesures
drastiques
où étiez vous où êtes vous monsieur le
premier ministre
où est l'état actionnaire qui doit taper
du poing sur la table pour faire cesser
cette chienlit qui portent atteinte à
l'un des fleurons notre pays
avez-vous pensé aux effets
catastrophiques sur les investissements
étrangers
air france n'est pas une entreprise
comme les autres
elles portent l'image de tout un pays
d'un savoir-faire de valeurs
d'excellence et d'accueil que doivent
penser aujourd'hui ces entreprises
internationales qui souhaitent investir
chez nous vont-elles retrouver leurs
dirigeants dans le même état que ceux
d'air france
vous avez une responsabilité directe
dans ce fiasco qui montre l'incapacité
de mener un réel dialogue social en
france où le patron est toujours montrée
du doigt la violence et l'intimidation
sont elles les nouveaux marqueurs des
syndicats qui ont appelé à voter pour
vous en 2012
d'ailleurs qu'attend le ps pour les
dénoncer
vous n'avez pas le droit de mettre en
péril notre compagnie nationale
c'est trop grave car air france c'est la
france
merci monsieur chrétien la parole à
monsieur le premier ministre
sur le seul député monsieur chrétien
vous remercie du caractère modéré est
absolument pas caricatural de votre
question et la situation d'air france
est suffisamment grave et sérieuse pour
aborder cette question avec le sérieux
nécessaire depuis plus d'un an avec
alain vidalis nous soutenons la
direction d'air france parce que air
france est confrontée à des défis
majeurs heures dont celui de la
concurrence et il n'y a pas d'autre
choix pour la compagnie nationale de
faire des réformes nécessaires partagé
par tous je me suis rendu ce matin même
à air france à roissy pour rendre
d'abord hommage et pour exprimer soutien
solidarité et affection je pense que
c'est partagé par chacun vis-à-vis des
deux cadres et de tous ceux qui ont été
humiliés frappé molesté et cet acte est
évidemment intolérable et il doit
il doit devra faire l'objet de sanctions
exemplaires
la justice a été saisie la police mène
une enquête
indispensable car dans notre pays pas
seulement pour l'image s'est déjà tout à
fait essentiel d'air france et de la
france mais ces images cette violence
sont intolérables et doivent être
évidemment condamné avec la plus grande
force et j'en appelle de nouveau à la
responsabilité de chacun et attention à
la confusion est d'abord des pilotes et
monsieur le député soyez sérieux que je
le sache je ne sache pas que le snpl et
a voté et appelé à voter en 2012 pour
françois hollande le syndicat des
pilotes qui se refuse à toute discussion
sérieuse sur l'avenir de la compagnie il
appartient aux pilotes d'air france de
faire preuve de lucidité eux qu'ils
accomplissent un métier admirez eux
qu'ils accomplissent une mission tout à
fait essentiel transporter des millions
de passagers tous les ans doivent faire
preuve de responsabilité
s'asseoir autour de la table discuter et
participer de la solution pour l'avenir
d'air france enfin monsieur le député un
dernier mot
la chienlit le mot que nous avons déjà
entendu en fin de matinée la remise en
cause permanente des corps
intermédiaires des syndicats de
l'indépendance de la justice de ceux qui
font de même la démocratie
ce mot chienlit l'expression qui a été
aussi la vôtre comme celles de nicolas
sarkozy sont des mots dangereux et je
crois que de plus en plus il y à un
débat dans le pays alors apprend t-on le
seul débat qui est sur une certaine
conception de la démocratie sur une
certaine vision de la france vous voulez
à bach séquences intermédiaires remettre
en cause les syndicats politisés et bien
non la négociation le dialogue social le
respect des corps intermédiaires le
respect de la démocratie
les syndicats comme des élus comme les
associations aidées à cela tout
simplement des français
cette idée de la france nous la
défendrons merci